salut les épicurieux vous me posez
beaucoup de questions sur les réseaux
sociaux et sur Youtube avec le hashtag
10 amis et notamment sur les animaux
comme je suis très à cheval sur le lien
qui nous unit et bien je les ai réunis
dans cette vidéo c'est parti
une question de Christelle Jupin
pourquoi les chats ronronnent
les scientifiques restent-elles n'ont
pas encore percé tous les mystères du
ronronnement mais en général si un chat
ronronne c'est parce qu'il se sent bien
les chatons ronronnent dès la première
tétée et leur mère aussi ce sont est
souvent un signe de bien-être
étonnamment les félins sauvages ne
semblent pas ronronner à l'âge adulte
sauf les mers avec leurs petits mais le
chat domestique lui aurait conservé ce
caractère juvénile comme moyen de
communication avec son maître par
exemple lorsque le maître caresse son
chat l'animal ronronne pour signifier
son bien-être pour dire continue à me
caresser le ronronnement n'est cependant
pas qu'un signe de bien-être il
participe car il libère chez le chat des
endorphines à neurotransmetteur messager
du bonheur il le détende lors d'un
examen vétérinaire par exemple ou face à
un congénère agressif un chat peut donc
aussi se mettre à ronronner pas par
plaisir une fois mais au contraire pour
se rassurer enfin d'après certaines
études les fréquences bases du
ronronnement auraient sur les eaux les
muscles et les tendons des chats à
pouvoir réparateur voire antidouleur
question de Clem pourquoi les papillons
de nuit sont-ils attirés par la lumière
parce qu'ils ont une vision
particulièrement adaptée à la vie
nocturne leurs deux yeux captent mille
fois plus de lumière que ce des
papillons de jour et c'est cette
incroyable vision nocturne ce qui leur
permet de voler en utilisant la Lune
comme repère on parle d'orientation
transversale en effet en gardant un
certain angle par rapport au rayon
lumineux de la lune ils n'ont aucun mal
à s'orienter dans le noir ce qu'on avait
pas prévu les papillons de nuit c'est
que le 27 janvier 1880 Thomas Edison
déposerait le brevet de l'ampoule à
incandescence grâce ou à cause de cette
ampoule tout dépend de quel côté on se
place homme ou papillon nuit les réseaux
électriques se sont développés à travers
le monde et des centaines de millions de
petites lunes ce sont mis à briller
encore plus forts que notre satellite
naturel attirant et dé les papillons qui
peuvent tourner pendant des heures
autour de ces sources lumineuses
artificielles et mourir d'épuisement
pourquoi dit-on rusé comme un renard
c'est une question de Johan saviez-vous
qu'avant d'être reprise par la fontaine
en 1668 la fable du corbeau et du renard
avait déjà été écrite notamment par
réseau un fabuliste grec plus de 1000
ans auparavant comme quoi la réputation
de cet animal ne date pas d'hier et ne
se contente pas à nos régions le renard
est réputé dans de nombreux pays sa
frimousse pleine de malice et sa
capacité à toujours trouver le moyen
d'entrer dans un poulailler ils sont
sûrement pas pour rien en France c'est
le Roman de Renard renard avec un T qui
est à l'origine de l'expression rusé
comme un renard vous l'avez peut-être
étudié à l'école en tout cas moi c'est
ce que j'ai fait l'histoire est
intéressante il s'agit d'un recueil
d'histoires animalière écrit entre le
12e et le 13e siècle par plusieurs
auteurs pas forcément connu d'ailleurs
l'animal dont on parle aujourd'hui et
qui apparaît dans les récits s'appelle à
l'époque un renard est alors un prénom
utilisé pour donner un titre au recueil
pourquoi renard personne ne le sait
vraiment les aventures de ce Goupil vont
devenir tellement populaires que le mot
renard va prendre la place du mot Goupil
pour désigner ce petit mammifère c'est
pas malin ça
Maëva aimerait savoir pourquoi les
chauves-souris se tiennent la tête en
bas cette posture est naturelle pour les
chauves-souris leurs pattes sont en
effet trop faibles pour supporter leur
poids et les propulser au moment de leur
envol en s'accrochant en hauteur tête en
bas il leur suffit au contraire de se
laisser tomber de profiter de l'élan de
la chute pour déployer leurs ailes et se
mettre à voler vivre tête en bas à
d'autres avantages pendus à la voûte
d'une grotte ou à la charpente d'une
grange elle se tiennent hors de portée
de certains prédateurs comme les chats
ou les serpents elles sont si bien
adaptées à cette posture que quand elle
se suspendent le poids de leur corps
tire sur les tendons de leur membres
inférieure ce qui bloque les griffes en
position d'accrochage comme si elles
étaient clipsées cette position est
tellement stable que des chauves-souris
peuvent rester accrochées même après
leur mort renversant non
une question de Patrick que voit les
chats quand ils se voient dans un miroir
on a fait plusieurs fois le test du
miroir avec des chats le principe de
cette expérience scientifique mise au
point dans les années 70 par le
psychologue américain Gordon galop est
le suivant on place sur l'animal une
petite marche une croix ou un disque de
couleur à un endroit bien visible sur
son front par exemple puis on installe
l'animal devant un miroir et on observe
sa réaction s'il se frotte pour tenter
de faire disparaître cette marque cela
signifie en principe qu'il a compris que
l'image qu'il voit dans le miroir et la
sienne le but est de mesurer ainsi la
perception que les animaux ont de même
si certaines espèces comme les
chimpanzés ou des grands mammifères
réussissent très bien ce test ce n'est
pas le cas des chats devant un miroir un
chat va tout au plus montrer de la
surprise ou de la colère face à ce qu'il
va considérer comme un intrus
consomme il peut n'avoir aucune réaction
en tout cas une chose est sûre il ne se
voit pas lui
la question de Louis Picard d'où vient
l'expression pleurer des larmes de
crocodile cette drôle d'expression
remontrait à une ancienne légende
égyptienne selon laquelle les crocodiles
du Nil attiraient leurs proies en
gémissant les imprenants qui
s'approchaient trop près pour découvrir
l'origine de ces plaintes se faisait
alors dévorer d'où l'utilisation de
cette expression pour décrire des larmes
hypocrites un faux chagrin plein
d'arrière-pensée mais au-delà de la
légende cette expression renvoie aussi à
une vraie particularité des crocodiles
il verse effectivement quelques larmes
lorsqu'ils mangent si si même si les
scientifiques ne connaissent pas la
cause exacte de ce phénomène peut-être
est-ce simplement une façon de protéger
leurs yeux à moins que ce ne soit
provoqué par les mouvements brusques
qu'ils font en mangeant une chose est
sûre cela n'a rien à voir avec un
quelconque remords ou chagrin envers
leurs proies
pourquoi les mouches ont-elles un vol si
erratique c'est une question de Benoît
paix en clair pourquoi veulent-elles
dans tous les sens c'est vrai qu'on peut
se poser la question parce que dans la
nature en plein air les mouches sont au
contraire un vol plutôt droit et dirigé
mais c'est vrai qu'entre 4 murs elle
virevolte et tourne sans arrêt parfois
pendant des heures et il y a une raison
à cela pour voler les mouches ne peuvent
s'appuyer que sur ce qu'elle voit elles
n'ont pas de radar contrairement aux
chauves-souris par exemple elles vont
donc plutôt se mettre à voler en cercle
à tourner en rond lorsqu'elle perçoivent
qu'elles sont dans un environnement clos
une pièce carrée ou rectangulaire tout
simplement parce que c'est la
trajectoire la plus sûre pour ne pas
rencontrer d'obstacle et oui elle
n'apprécie pas plus que nous de se
cognir au mur à folle layette la mouche
retrouver ses amis du lundi au vendredi
à 16h55 sur France 5 ou dès maintenant
sur le lien est sous cette vidéo et
surtout n'hésitez pas à vous abonner et
activer la cloche faites le savoir
[Applaudissements]